on va passer au débat du jour parce que
ça c'était même pas le débat du jour cé
just le voilà on va revenir sur l'affire
Théo pour ceux qui ne s'en souviennent
pas Théo avait été grillamment blessé à
l'anus lors de son interpellation Renée
sousb en 2017 un coup avec la pointe
d'un bâton télescopique de policier
avait été à l'origine de sa blessure
cette semaine et jusqu'à demain trois
policiers de 31 34 et 42 ans sont jugés
devant la Cour d'assise de sensand des
peines allant de 3 mois à 3 ans de
prison avec surci ont été requises à
l'encontre des policiers alors
trouvez-vous ça trop sévère 3 ans de
prison avec surcis requis contre les
policiers trouvez-vous ça trop sévère
oui non on en parle dans un instant avec
Cyril her Herm qui vient souvent nous
voir qui connait bien l'affaire qui va
nous en parler syndicaliste policier
d'abord on regarde la réaction de Théo
au tribunal tout à l'heure il s'est
satisfait des réquisitions regardez tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier l'avocat
général mes propres avocats qui ont fait
une très belle PL à mon égard et qui ont
réétabli la vérité ce qui est pour moi
plus important que toute chose qui ont
bien mise en valeur le fait que je n'ai
jamais MTI dans C cette histoire et
concern les P requis ben je ne sais pas
de la Justice M moi tout convientant
qu'ils sont condamnés par ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est tout ce qui compte en vrai de
vrai donc maintenant que ce soit 50 ans
30 ans c'est pas mon but c'est pas c'est
pas mon travail moi mon travail avant
c'était des des là ce qui s'est passé et
qu'on dise à tout le monde ce qui s'est
passé c'est la vérité merci sir qui avec
nous vous êtes conseiller régional
centre Val de Loire et syndicaliste
policier est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler l'affaire Tho en quelques mots
oui alors l'affaire Tho en fait c'est
quoi c'est un point de deal dans la cité
des 3000 un équipage de BST qui va faire
un contrôle et alors que le le le le
contrôle est en train de de s'effectuer
on a un individu de forte corpulence qui
vient mettre en difficulté les
fonctionnaire de police intervenant et
cet individu CTO alors vous vous
racontez à votre façon aussi je le
raconte à une façon policière mais si
vous voulez je peux le raconter
autrement vous avez un contrôle de Poce
vous avez un contrôle de police dans la
cité des 3000 pendant le contrôle police
vous avez un individu qui arrive et qui
interpelle les policiers qui son TR de
procéder au contrôle interposé une
interpellation
pas bien
PRC c'est quo
l'istoire s'interpose pour éviter que la
situation ne dégénère là il est agressé
par un policier c'est le terme du
ministère public aujourd'hui qui a dit
qu'il y avait pas de légitime défense et
que la violence n'était pas légitime du
tout de la part du policier et le
policier l'a grièvement blessé à lanus
d'ailleurs Théo emporte aujourd'hui
lesestigmates il les portera à vie voilà
je pense qu'il faut quand même utiliser
les les mots bonéciant la légitime
défense là n'est pas en cause on a une
interpellation qui est qui est en train
de se prod le ministère public qui l'a
dit aujourd'hui min le ministère public
il il est très gentil he l'avocat
général ah oui mais il propose 3 ans de
surc contre le policier soit le policier
a Siam voulu blessto et lui mettre son
bâton télescopique dans l'anus au quel
cas 3 ans c'est rien du tout c'est même
anormal soit il n'a pas voulu faire ça
et il est innocent de ses faits et là 3
ans c'est énorme là je trouve que les
réquisitions de l'avocat général sont ni
faites ni à faire et je dis ça en toute
objectivité alors juste il y a Cédric
Vladimir policier qui a donné sa vie sur
l'affaire regardez il parle aussi
d'escroquerie médiatique regardez qu'on
nous vend c'est qure ou C policiers
néonazis qui ont trouver un noir qui se
baladait par là ils ont dit tiens on va
l'attraper le mettre dans un coin lui
baisser son pantalon et lui enfoncer une
matraque dans les fesses finalement on a
plutôt quatre policiers qui sont sous
effectif dans au plein milieu d'un point
de Deal finalement le viol ça serait
plutôt bah des policiers qui sont qui se
sont fait gazer qui ont pris des coups
de Po qui sont par terre et il y a un
coup de matraque qui vient taper dans
une fesse et qui vient lui faire une
fissure anale donc on est quand même
loin de la version début sauf que la
version qui a été vendue médiatiquement
c'est la version de début et c'est celle
qui va rester dans la tête des gens mais
aujourd'hui vous demandez à la plupart
des Français qui est Tho Tho c'est un
jeune qui s'est fait violer par des
policiers alors Gill verd vous trouvez
que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas trop
sévère non moi je trouve que c'est
franchement la juste proportion
l'inspection général de la police
nationale avait d'ailleurs dit que
l'usage de la force était
disproportionné donc moi je tr trve
c'est normal Théo d'ailleurs a été
extrêmement calme et il a dit le
principal c'est qu' est condamnation peu
importe que ce soit 50 ans 10 ans 3 mois
avec surcis moi je trouve que la raison
a prévalu et ces policiers pour moi
doivent être condamnés et je je trouve
que 3 ans de prison avec surcis c'est la
juste peine monsieur voilà je voudrais
un un un oui oui a qui card pourquoi moi
je suis de l'avis de ceux qui pensent
que ces réquisitions n'ont pas de sens
ce que vous venez de dire les
réquisitions elles sont elles sont trop
fortes moi j'en ai marre que
systématiquement lorsque il y a une
interpellation qui se passe mal euh ce
soit finalement les policiers qui soient
qui soi condamnés la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé euh c'est que si Théo
s'était laissé faire et s'il s'était
laissé menoter euh on il y aurait pas eu
ce qui s'est passé après ça c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est avéré oui
mais ce qui s'est passé après n'est pas
qui s'est fait qui s'est pas fait violer
parce que le terme n'est pas n'est pas
retenu il y a eu un coup malheureux
là-dessus tout le monde est d'accord le
policier le reconna euh celui qui a
porté le C qui a retrouvé quand même Tho
allongé non je suis d'accord mais enfin
le le le la scène fait que il ne s'est
pas laissé men noter il s'est rebellé il
ça s'est mal passé avec le premier
policier puis il a fallu que les trois
autres se mettent sur l'autre enfin sur
le sur Tho lui-même ainsi que sur le
policier et donc c'est c'est c'est voilà
c'est on est encore dans une affaire où
malheureusement celui qui est la victime
il est la victime il y a aucun problème
là-dessus bah s'il s'était laissé faire
on nen serait pas arrivé là après moi je
pense qu'il y a une valeur d'exemple
c'est que moi je suis pas d'accord avec
cette société où finalement à chaque
fois que les policiers essent d'arrêter
quelqu'un parce que ça se passe mal au
final ils auraient des réquisitions qui
sont très élevé je dis pas qu'ils
doivent pas être condamnés mais je pense
que 3
ansve vous pas donné la
parole pas comme ça pas comme
ça pas comme ça que ça se passe voil je
vous dis Mo je trouve que c'estès liqué
sur un plateau télé dans notre petit
confort de se dire qu'est-ce qu'on
aurait fait à la place de ces policiers
qui arrive sur le parvis des 3000 dans
un milieu quand même hostile puisque à
l'époque avant que la mairie ne change
je crois que c'était vraiment un point
de Deal très très actif donc voilà ils
sont là ça se passe mal évidemment Théo
vient sur eux enfin qu'est-ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas-là alors peut-être leur
seule erreur effectivement c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas su mettre Théo loin de loin de
ça en fait ils ont pas su le lexture de
ce projet l'exfiltrer ça c'est peut-être
leur erreur après moi quand je vois
aujourd'hui Théo je trouve qu M and même
assez admirable je trouve qu'il a pas de
haine pas de vengeance je trouve qu'il
s'exprime très très bien franchement je
trouve c'est plutôt un un modèle je
trouve qu' est il est très fort moi il
m'impressionne beaucoup je pense que la
vie de Tho est dévastée comme la vie du
policier parce que il y a des
réquisitions vous avez dit certes 3 ans
avec surcier mais il y aussi 5 ans
d'interdiction de mission de police et 5
ans de non port d'armes donc je pense
que la vie de ce policier qui était
exemplaire jusqu'à présent est est foutu
et la vie de Tho est peut-être aussi
très bah c'est quand même compliqué je
pense qu'il porte ce truc là quand même
ce sera jamais celui qui mal
et qui vient s'ajouter au fait que
jusqu'à présent il n'exerce plus de
fonction de policier aussi hein donc ça
fait déjà 5 ans alors mais il faut pas
passionner le truc parce que justeon VO
le sondage s'il vous plaît le sondage
s'il vous plaît merci euh voilà TR oui
sévère trop sévère à 68 % non à à à 31 %
j'ai on a deux débats aujourd'hui donc
vous allez réagir à l'autre c'est la
fideraquel garido et Alex Corbier pouvez
rester d'ailleurs làdessus j'aimerais
voir votre avis placé en garde à vue
pour apologie du terrorisme les parents
sont-ils responsables euh et oui elle a
été interpellée par les enquêteurs de la